[Musica]
ma sono le sette e mezza del mattino
alle 7 del mattino ho mai visto staccata
da certamente né lo stimo per favore ce
l'hai proprio scritto sulla tazzina ce
lo farà non anche la paura
[Musica]
i ragazzi sono le otto del mattino non
mattina con questo pirla qua che mi ha
svegliato un'oretta fa perché cantando
ti pavarotti cioè che mi sta portando
non ho idea di dove mi stia portando
quindi scopriremo tra poco
[Musica]
io prego
ciao ragazzi sono venuti accomodatevi un
giorno lorenzo coltrondo lorenzo ci stai
domandando no no ma tu sei land in siria
di seconda
no no non solo libri ma dove che mi
stanno portando cioè io veramente
continuavo a chiedermelo dal minuto 1 e
continuo a chiedermelo tuttora anche se
so dove mi hanno portato ben pensarci
scusa a fare un collegamento dai ma
senti mai stato veramente cosa c'entra
qualcosa
ragazzi miei vodafone mi ha appena
mandato un pacco una chiave
ovviamente le cantonate fu una chiave
grazie c'è una lettera alla deco perché
è stato punto c'era un significato
piccolo indizio
hai qualche amico che polpi capito
divano allora addio al re deve fare il
serio è un secondo non riesce perché è
una prova importante e qui sta per
succedere una rover no ma è la prima
volta vede una cartellina col mio logo
sono emozionato quindi già così la pensa
di questa casa tua
questa mattina sta in trappola
situazione perché mio padre me lo spiego
perché sei pronto
no allo zio 6 king della tecnologia
grazie sei king di youtube
aggiungerei comuni usi la tecnologia per
unire le persone esattamente come fa
molto e quindi oggi c'è una sorpresa per
te che per la tua community
e tutto quello che stanno per
presentarti questi due baldi giovani è
per alzare l'asticella il next level per
i tuoi contenuti
prego piacere lorenzo
[Musica]
vodafone è incaricato di creare la tua
gaming room la
mi sa cosa ha la gaming room quindi si
no ma chiaro potrà dirlo subito quella
la gaining room la stanza la stanza
piena di flipper quella dei minuti ma la
facciamo esattamente anzi la fate
esattamente come voglio io
narnia non lo mette dentro fanno tutta
la stanza ma anche senso mi serve sapere
quali sono i tuoi gusti quali sono le
cose da cui ti ispiri
coloro siano colori film giochi che ti
piacciono dei grafi allora io vorrei
fare una cosa che è un misto tra
tecnologia è un qualcosa di natura cioè
secondo me lo stile giapponese ecco che
la mia gaming room la immagino un po
come se fosse uno spazio museale ma
anche futuristica una via di mezzo
perché comunque vorrei che ci fossero
degli elementi fisici che rappresentano
il mio mondo ma anche che stupiscano a
livello di tecnologia
no però aspetta c'è io comunque al mio
studio ci sono abbastanza affezionato
cioè quindi non è che adesso bottino
tutto anche chi pensi di parlare con te
ecco guarda i suoi superpoteri e
arrivano tutti i lavori per cui cisco io
allora quelle cuffie valgono veramente
un sacco perché commesse la prima volta
ho iniziato a fare video quindi lorenzo
stai tranquillo e posa le immediatamente
cioè dove metter mettetevi al sicuro per
favore
ma quindi non si limita allo studio si
può fare dallo studio la camera guida
lorello che perfetto la partiamo dal
bagno gabinetto con la tavoletta
riscaldata lei mai provato sì ma serba
di base del giappone
[Musica]
dice che è la parte fondamentale del tuo
lavoro come lo vuoi piccolo grande
facciamo un computer incredibile ma se
riusciamo ad aggiungerci qualche chicca
che un compito maerna tipo io vedo ci
sono la vita che fanno le bibite si può
lavorare anche su quella che è una
bibita preferita
facciamo in modo di avere un computer
che all'interno alla tua bibita
preferita e poi erogarla magari
vocalmente così anche senza neanche
schiacciarmi magari aiuter fanny quando
qualche tuo folle guerra si iscrive al
tuo canale si può dire poi le tiriamo
fuori preferisci elicottero privato
ecco questa è una domanda importante è
piaciuto come incalzato mai direi jet
privato una bella rampa qua va bene la
cartellina
grazie a questa di serre bellissimo
volto anche per riportarla tutti gli
appuntamenti andremo quando signori
grazie milano piacere grazie al comando
della mia vita grazie alla fine vedi che
è servito alzarsi presto perché comunque
il risultato è che è un'ottima giornata
[Musica]